The next lifetime, I would like to put in an order
for your legs, if that's okay?
Oh okay.
I now have the visual of the legs I've always wanted.
Drew, should we just trade now?
Yes.
They zip off.
Here you go.
Okay, great.
Okay, perfect.
'Cause I do feel girlfriendy with you.
And I wonder if that's something that,
people sort of have that barrier broken with you
because of Girls.
It's literally the ten year anniversary,
and,
(audience applauds)
It was so groundbreaking
Obviously, like we all, when we were making Girls
were like, we think this is really great and important,
but like, you just never know.
And so the fact that it had the response that it did
was like, I mean, it was life changing obviously.
And because we all played these characters
that were just like bearing our souls and our bodies
and our lives, people felt like they knew us.
And I think particularly Shoshanna as a character
who's just so out there and unabashed in who she is
and is an oversharer herself.
So yes, I think people felt like they were my best friend.
I would get A, a lot of people
who didn't necessarily recognize me from the show,
but they thought they knew me.
So, like I've literally had showdowns
with people in airports where they're like,
"You went to camp Ottawa with me!"
And I'm like, "Look, I promise."
(Drew laughs)
I think I would remember.
"I would not lie.
Actually not having gone to summer camp
was like a really sore subject for me
because I didn't get to go.
I was not in cabin eight with you.
You've mistaken me for someone else."
Oh my God. I have that same thing.
I never got to go to a camp.
And all I did was watch Meatballs and every camp movie.
Oh, Camp Nowhere?
Little Darlings-
On repeat.
Which is highly inappropriate.
But like the best movie ever.
1,000 Percent.
But is it true that you and your husband live in a cabin?
We do, yes. Kind of.
Part of our house is,
the original structure's this 1920s Sears catalog cabin.
Oh my God. I love those.
Those are actually the additions to the house
that we didn't put on.
But the front of the house is like a legit,
like there's not one nail in it.
It's like a full-on log cabin.
That's so cool.
Is it true that your husband, who is an actor,
but also liaisons as a contractor?
Yes, he-
Lucky you.
I mean, you guys, I really hit the jackpot.
He's also a great cook.
Oh my God.
I mean, I know.
You deserve that.
It's a little silly.
(audience applauds)
How did you guys meet?
Look at that handsome man.
We met doing a play together and we fell in love immediately
and we dated secretly for the whole run of the show,
which was very fun and exciting.
Uh-huh.
And then like a week before the show wrapped
we totally got caught, fully red-handed.
Did somebody walk in on you guys?
Not quite, our schedule was a little bit funny
with our Saturday matinees.
And for some reason would swap
between two and three o'clock.
And so we were like,
"Yeah, we have a three o'clock matinee."
And we were like having a really lazy Saturday,
and we'd ordered in food-
Mm-hmm.
and we'd like had a shower together.
And we were just having a nice time.
And all of a sudden we both looked at our phones
and we had like 25 missed calls and it was 1:48
and we did not have a three o'clock matinee,
we had a two o'clock matinee.
And we were both in towels with wet hair.
In that moment, actually, we were like,
we kind of knew that we were meant to be together,
'cause we were like, "This is the first true crisis."
And we both were like, you call the cab,
I'm gonna get dressed. I'm gonna do this.
I'm gonna call the stage manager,
like you, boom, boom, boom.
And we just like, and we got there with two minutes to spare
and we went on stage.
I think it was actually one of our earliest curtains.
We went on at like 2:05.
But we fully walked in and we were like,
"Hmm. We were having lunch together."
(audience laughs)
And everyone was like,
(audience applauds)
really, lunch?
(bright theme music)